est ce que vous connaissez le terme
politique ce que vous savez c'est quoi
la politique la candidate libérale
rencontre des élèves syrien arrivé à
montréal au cours de la dernière année
moi je veux que le canada devienne un
négociateur en chef de la pet l'automne
dernier c'est écoles arméniennes
accueillait 18 jeunes ayant fui la gare
ils sont maintenant 87 font beaucoup
d'efforts pour s'adapter mais ils sont
très très heureux surtout de pouvoir
aller à l'école c'est vrai ça en cours
de français mélanie joly présente à la
directrice les engagements libéraux
envers les réfugiés en accueillir 25 mai
le plus tôt possible et verser 100
millions ou province pour faciliter leur
intégration
madame joly prend promet des millions de
dollars alors on s'y attend justement
donc ça va influencer votre fort
probablement dans le quartier ville 60%
des habitants sont nés à l'étranger ou
au moins un parent né à l'extérieur
beaucoup d'haïtiens d'algériens et
d'arabes du moyen orient ajoute les
libanais et on vote pour les libéraux
charles abou jaoude coiffes des
libanaises et syriennes ici depuis 25
ans selon lui leur vote n'est plus et
qui nous libérons ont besoin de
changement ma charge c'est ça qu'on veut
ça n'est plus chez les libéraux pour
vous malheureusement non
l'investiture libérale retardé pour
favoriser mélanie joly au détriment des
autres candidats tous issus des
communautés immigrantes a laissé des
traces
3 il ya de la gare aux 100 mégas je suis
très inquiète
dans vous allez voter pour qui
pour qui c'est une question très
important maintenant on pose la question
pour qui cette question mais mon opinion
à moi je trouve je vais donner la chance
à madame maria mourani d'origine
libanaise
maria mourani et député ici depuis neuf
ans le bloc québécois l'a exclu du
caucus
quand elle s'est opposée à la charte des
valeurs du gouvernement marois elle se
présente maintenant comme néo démocrate
a nous a trahis
j'ai voté pour elle tout le temps là je
suis fâché parce qu'elle nous a trahis
or que voulez vous c'est sûr qu'il ya
des gens qui n'ont pas compris pourquoi
je suis parti etc
mais je rencontre aussi beaucoup de
souverainistes qui me le dise il me dit
je suis souverainiste
vous êtes ma députée ça fait neuf ans
fait un excellent travail
on va voter pour vous c'est la vente
trottoir ce jour là sur la rue fleury
juste à côté du kiosque de madame
mourani celui d'écologistes qui
s'opposent au projet de pipeline énergie
est c'est lui qui risque de polluer 250
cours d'eau au québec
sept militants demandent pourquoi le npd
ne se pose pas clairement ou pipeline
nous on paye et on a été très clair pas
d'études environnementales crédit pas de
paille
un peu plus loin sur la rue fleury
le candidat du bloc québécois échange
avec une haïtienne qui lui pose des
questions sur l'indépendance du québec
comment vous comptez potvin de ce projet
à des gens
comme nous de nouveaux arrivants on veut
voir rayonner le québec à
l'international
mais là justement on détient pas ces
moyens là ce dernier mandat harper le
ministre des relations internationales
en ce moment est unilingue anglais et
que dit-il aux souverainistes qui
pourraient bouder le bloc dont le but de
défaire le gouvernement harper ne lisez
pas des députés fédéralistes c'est sûr
qu'ils vont se battre contre si un
référendum
éventuellement si le mp2 et des idées
beaucoup en avance il va vraiment
ressortir ce souverainiste est hanté par
les néo démocrates mais il juge que les
engagements de thomas mulcair demeure
trop floue la plupart des candidats
n'ont pas encore dit comment il compte
créer des emplois dans le comté ni
combien le chômage ici dépasse 11% et
aucun investissement aucun emploi créé
dans ses quartiers depuis neuf ans et en
ce sens là où je suis très critique
directe de la députée en place désolé
c'est pas vrai si je prends par exemple
la section qu'elle parle chabanel si on
prend deux avec des justes avec le
programme développement économique
canada
on a développé entre 2011 et 2013 la
1000 au dessus de 1000 emplois maria
mourani a été élu trois fois avec de
faibles majorité elle s'attend à une
autre lutte très serrée et se prépare à
se coucher très tard le 19 octobre